AND HE HUSTLES AND THROWS IT OFF
OF HIM.
AND HE HAS IT.
>> Kelenna: THAT WAS BIG TIME
DEFENSE AND LOONEY, AN EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT HE HAS IT BACK.
HE COULD NOT MAKE THAT PASS.
>> Bob: LOONEY, DEFENSIVELY AND
TRACKING TOWN THE LOOSE BALL AND
NOT LETTING IT -- TRACKING DOWN
THE LOOSE BALL AND NOT LETTING
IT BE OFF OF IT.
LEADING THE BALL.
STEPH THOUGHT ABOUT THE STEP
BACK PLAY.
AND NOW, BURY A THREE.
21 FOR KLAY THOMPSON.
>> Kelenna: WAS THERE EVER A
DOUBT?
AS SOON AS KLAY GOT IT, HE IS
LIKE, THIS IS WHAT I TO, I MAKE
THOSE TYPE OF SHOTS.
>> Bob: THE THUNDER CROWD OVER
THE YEARS, THEY ARE LIKE, NOT
THAT GUY AGAIN.
>> Kelenna: LOOK AT LOONEY
THOUGH.
THE EFFORT, THE SMARTS MAKE SURE
HE FINDS STEPH AND STEPH IS
ABOUT TO TAKE GIDDEY, BUT HE
DECIDES TO GIVE IT TO HIS SPLASH
BROTHER.
HE KNOWS WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
.
>> Bob: AND FOR BAZLEY, THAT IS
A MENTAL ERROR WHY ARE YOU OFF
OF KLAY THOMPSON.
IF YOU ARE PLAYING THE WARRIORS,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY OTHER
THAN THOSE TWO GUYS BEAT YOU.
>> Kelenna: ANY SPACE IS TOO